and the td entertainer of the year award
goes to my brother
dallas smith uh wow entertainer of the
year
and then top-selling album top-selling
single how are you gonna celebrate
tonight
uh i'm gonna go to bed early i think i'm
gonna
yeah it felt like we haven't entertained
in a while that's the thing
well dallas may have gone for a more
modest celebration of his three wins
but over in edmonton brett kissel rolled
out his own red carpet to celebrate his
four wins
alongside his family we all got dressed
up
i rented a red carpet and we put it in
our living room
it's so great that we get to celebrate
together
as a family because every year we never
get to
we're always busy we're tonight we
celebrate each other
do you drink about me
teneal towels was also celebrating with
three awards of her own including video
of the year and her second straight win
for
female artist of the year it is just my
great honor to hold this and to give
my whole heart to attempt to leave a few
more footsteps behind for
the little dreamers and and girls
writing songs at home
teneal's amazing night came less than
two weeks after she won new female
artist of the year at the american
country music awards
is that really a conscious thing that
you think about when you're when you're
making music and when you're developing
your career about
the mark you're making or the role model
you're being for younger girls
to me that is such a great honor and
is definitely something that i i care
about so much in my heart it
very much i think is something i'm
conscious of all the time
but obviously we're having a very weird
2020. so
how does this fit into your 2020. it is
a really weird time to celebrate and
there's a there's a lot of heaviness in
the world right now and
i think now more than ever i'm grateful
for the music
yeah the impact of the ongoing health
crisis was definitely felt last night
in more ways than one while the washburn
union held on to their group or duo of
the year
title for the third consecutive year and
roots album of the year for the fifth
year in a row
they opted not to stage a performance
due to safety concerns
we take that very seriously and we hope
that you know all our friends and
and all canadians take it as seriously
as we do and james barker band who took
home single of the year for their hit
keep it simple were split between
burrell's creek and nashville for
their performance
[Music]
and nothing but soaking up the sunshine
we own summer time
how difficult was that to do the ccmas
were amazing this year they allowed us
to get super creative with this because
we were like
i mean how are we going to do this we
got two of us in canada two of us in
america obviously it's not safe for us
to be getting together through the magic
of technology
we were able to make it happen and this
year's show was also a notable one for
teneal arts
who scored her very first ccma victory
with the rising star award which has
previously gone to breakout acts like
the wreck laws and megan patrick
i can't even believe this is real right
now what does it feel like getting
that label i mean it's really cool like
you said looking back at
so many artists that you know this is
kind of the starting point for them they
win this award and then the next year
it's even bigger you know so
it's super exciting